it is the nightmare we've all been
dreading the government failing us when
we need it most and the health system
collapsing in Ecuador it happens so
badly that bodies were left to rot on
the streets these scenes may be receding
but the aftermath is devastating Blanka
race is on the way to the hospital again
looking for her father's body a month
after they called to say the virus had
killed him
Taniya it's a following former comedian
Eddie goes Emily say no super elf is you
porfavor ascetical celibate adding to
blanka's grief in the month that's past
the hospital still has no answers about
where her father is a death certificate
but no body to bury
but this game can you be answer winner
okay kiss icing on for Saco Mona's
incommunicado familiarity por eso no
solo in Korea no solo que entra gar
porque el principio cariago quilter 1/10
oz fire Samira toes protect I'll call it
why kill has been one of Latin America's
worst hit cities it's thought as many as
7,000 have died in this one city alone
from the virus there hasn't been enough
help for the sick and here there was no
help when they died
this family had to keep the body of
their father in their home for three
days having to treat it with lime to
stop it decomposing in the heat yeah
wonderful sure I software McKinley's
hello pay or porque prácticamente Hong
Kong a singular predicament Antonia a
king a queen I thought our complete car
he separate opera familia - it in a
turkey a la persona you know Paula said
nah
they're afraid of speaking out here one
doctor was prepared to talk to Sky about
the government's failure and the backlog
of bodies but on condition we protect
his identity around the mortuary and the
A&E the smell was thick
it was stinking a lot very strong it
smelt of death there were areas that
were closed and you could see flies
swarming because of the number of deaths
three containers full that's a lot in
normal times fifty people died on
average a day in the city they've had up
to 600 a day during the pandemic
cardboard coffins haven't been enough
the official in charge of disposing of
the dead admits they've been overwhelmed
nobody's prepared for a tsunami and
nobody in the world is prepared for a
pandemic like this nobody because there
is fear involved in all this process we
had some complications I cannot say that
we we have not but we are we have been
trying to do our best to try with an to
live with this pandemic situation
so one family after another waits
outside the cemetery for their turn
having to bury their dead themselves
despite the risk of infection with
little social distancing and authorities
in disarray the risk of a second wave
here is very real
Dominic Waghorn Sky News